good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
today I'm going to be answering
questions about love and romance because
you know I'm such an expert in the field
why am I so scared of rejection well
because it's scary but the important
thing to remember is that everyone is
afraid of rejection they just don't seem
that way because you're not busy living
inside of their thoughts how do I know
if my boyfriend is about to porpoise
okay the first sign I would look for is
that your boyfriend might be spending a
lot of time in the water in fact if your
boyfriend is about to porpoise he might
feel increasingly uncomfortable on land
he may also start to look increasingly
less human and more dolphin shaped but
without the beak so yeah I would say if
you notice any of that stuff then your
boyfriend is probably going to porpoise
pretty soon oh wait you probably meant
how can I tell when my boyfriend's gonna
propose mmm see why spelling matters the
number one way to find out if your
boyfriend is going to propose is to ask
him and to talk about it because it's
weird that in our culture for some
reason marriage is something thrust upon
women like boys get to spend six months
deciding if they want to get married but
then the girl only has like 10 seconds
to say yes or no where are all the nerdy
girls okay dude I don't want you to
freak out but they're right here
seriously do they're like watching us
right now so yeah just keep cool don't
let them know that you know that they're
here and just you know play it confident
is it weird having your first kiss I
want to know because I think I might
have my first kiss soon and I don't want
to be too nervous okay first I need to
know if you mean like kiss or if you
mean like kiss by the way that was not
intended as a demonstration of proper
kissing technique because like the kiss
no big whoop nothing to be nervous about
though like I love love kiss I'm gonna
level with you you should be nervous
about that listen it's probably gonna go
poorly but if I can give you just one
piece of advice the human tongue is a
fantastic organ it's great for tasting
without it's speech would be impossible
but I would argue that it should not be
the primary combatant of any kiss you
know the Marines always say that their
first to fight the tongue should not be
first to kiss the tongue is like the
Navy SEALs you know they're like in and
out so fast
almost didn't even know they were there
what is the average number of times boys
need to be broken up with before they
realize that girls don't like needy
clingy boys 53 when two nerdfighters are
at nerdfighter life but then they need
some time apart
what is that phenomenon called breaking
off is it still acceptable to ask
someone out by writing them a note in
which you ask them to check either yes
or no do you think it's still allowed to
write a note where you ask someone to
check yes or no it totally worked with
Jennifer Keene and third grade so back
off it works I'm just saying that it's
not it's never been cool
it's always the wimps way what do you
recommend instead askin with your voice
yeah what if it Quivers how does a nerd
went over a beauty queen I don't know
maybe I'd start by offering it peanut
butter flavored treats no wait that's
how you went over a puppy I don't know
how to win over a beauty queen I've
never tried I'm almost 18 and I've never
been out on a date or how to boyfriend
and I get really shy around guys is that
weird or not weird it's not weird and
you might be surprised to learn how not
weird it is but as far as getting shy
around guys goes it's important to
remember that they are you know people
in exactly the same way that girls are
people is it still called nerdfighter
like if one person in the relationship
is a nerdfighter and the other isn't no
that's called interneural dating do guys
really not like girls who are smarter
than them the Venn diagram of guys who
don't like smart girls and guys you
don't want to date is a circle is
breaking up over text message bad yes
how do you get over crushing shyness to
ask a boy out on a date
just ask I mean actually call him right
now before you even finish watching this
video just call him and say John Green
said I had to call you I like you a
little bit I want to go out on a date no
big whoop Hank thanks for being awesome
and I'll see you tomorrow